and in our book TV bus is John's secret
young his book is called remains non
viewable a memoir what is it about well
it's it's about a in one sense a New
England family and my cousin Doug I was
one of 22 cousins just on that one side
of the family my dad was one of 10 and
he went off to Vietnam and was killed
and so some of the stories about waiting
for him to come back and the family
gathering and some of course is about
growing up in New England and the sort
of lessons of fathers and sons and how
in New England of course taciturnity is
is the goal I mean silence is nirvana
so in our family this event happened but
though Doug when bodies came back from
Vietnam there were sort of two
categories remains viewable or remains
non viewable Doug's body was actually
viewable but the subject matter within
the family once it happened was non
viewable it was something had happened
you don't talk about it basically the
assumption is there are no consequences
or aftermath or after-effects and
metaphorically I think that was true
about Vietnam itself we didn't want to
think about it talk about a deal with it
learn from it all of which is you know
not what happens after a war whether
it's a quote good war or bad war it has
impact on those who served and those in
the families of those who served how old
were you when Doug was killed I was uh
22 and under what circumstances did did
he die well you know the family you
first almost nothing
eventually we heard that the wonderful
phrase friendly-fire I did not know
actually into the book was published
I've learned more since from people who
have called me who were there when Doug
was there and said that he's you know
the the awful circumstances where it
wasn't that he was shot by another
American as he was apparently the
American Patrol walked into a trap the
South Vietnamese had said and they fired
on the Americans who ostensibly were
their allies but you know it's it's very
much a tale of a you know
he was what he went in was like 19 and a
half or 20 years old and there certainly
was looking for adventure and in his
innocence you know I sometimes think
it's like Huck Finn getting on the wrong
Mississippi you know looking for
adventure in the wrong places and you
know the book starts with a question of
sort of what happened over there how was
he killed and in a way I'm not sure you
ever find the exact answer or enough of
an answer to that and then it course
becomes a question of will what who was
he when he left who was the boy man that
I knew you know what was our family what
lessons were we taught by our dads and I
suppose in some way what how did that
help for me and turn me into a writer
that subject which has haunted me but
obviously not me alone
did you feel that that the New England
part of this was really the key to the
silence or have you found out have you
found that the silence among families of
Vietnam participants who died is
universal well I think New England has a
unique quality of silence but there is
no doubt that when men serve and they
come back many of them do not talk about
their experiences you know I did a show
for four years called China Beach and we
found the letters that we got were not
only about can I have an autographed
picture of Dana Delany or marg
Helgenberger who were in the show was
often letters from the wives of the sons
and daughters of you know the mothers
our fathers of veterans who were saying
our son or daughter did not talk about
their experiences all until maybe they
were sitting beside us in an episode of
your show was on the air and then they
started to talk you know a couple of
years ago bill Broyles who created the
show with me and I spoke at the Lyndon
Johnson Library in Austin Texas and we
were amazed at how we were then sort of
confronted by people who were saying
that just now and this is like 2005 that
their family members were sometimes just
talking about what had happened to them
but wasn't that true of the generation
before of the men and women who were
coming back from World War two well
you know war has a tendency to either
the experiences are so primal you know
if you survive you know you are lucky
you know there isn't justice and who
lives and who dies it isn't based on
good or bad your best friend can be next
to you one moment and be you know mush
the next and when you come back this
sort of the tous the two solutions are I
can't talk about it I don't know how to
deal with it I don't how to express it
or I turn it into an anecdote you know
God knows the Armed Forces whether it's
about paperwork or whether it's about
the food I mean you turn it into yarn or
anecdote or joke or laughter to try and
protect those deeper things that you
carry with inside you you talk about the
impact of the people around the person
who served and who died what was the
impact on your family and on Doug's
family what were the repercussions well
I think again the New England component
is that this that we seem to
successfully bury that for so long I
think the ramifications are that you
know in any family it just isn't right
when your son or daughter dies before
you do so I think it through the next
generation off kilter it's not as if
they all went on benders my dad was an
alcoholic I don't think that's the
reason I think it may have fed one of
the many ingredients that may have fed
it but you know it it played out in a
way where I think it led not to the
dissolution of family members but a sort
of disconnection an inability to
communicate only furthered by what
happened you know and in some cases it's
only now that we're starting to say
let's talk about it or let's just sort
of reach across that and recognize how
emotional it was and how it still is
emotional right on the surface if you
start to talk about it or deal with it
had you thought this completely through
before China Beach no not at all I think
that for years I wrote around the truth
you know I wrote a miniseries based on a
book by a man named Philip Caputo called
a rumor of war I wrote you know and
create a co-creator with Bill China
Beach and then I tried to do a mini
serie huge miniseries about sort of the
American experience in Vietnam which
probably not surprisingly never got made
and I think once in a way that my dad
and my uncle I was also close to Doug's
father died it allowed me to say now is
the time to think about who were they
what was that Greatest Generation
because so many of them served as well
and what were the lessons sometimes
explicit and sometimes implicit of what
it was to be a man that that we had been
left with and that you know that I carry
with me still and of course now that I
have children you start to realize oh my
god I'm passing on these lessons
sometimes knowingly sometimes not to you
know my own sons and daughters so from
China Beach you also went did the the
other side of it you were working on the
human side of it and in this book to the
West Wing which is pretty far removed
from the day-to-day the day-to-day life
of someone who might have lost their
life and or what was that like well I
think one of the things is you know I
also did a miniseries about the Gulf War
for summary or the guys coming home and
hey you know there's no such thing quote
unquote as Gulf War Syndrome but why are
all these men and women have these
mysterious illnesses well some of it
people stay sometimes it's psychological
well does that mean it's not an illness
because there are ramifications of
watching you know horrible things happen
around you well isn't that human indeed
to have to deal to have to kind of
wrestle with that inside yourself and
West Wing I think what it offered was
you know one very very smart show I came
in not at the beginning I came on to a
sort of a moving train but you know job
was I was a writer producer on it and
sort of came in as a almost of counsel
if we're a law firm you know some some
you know some people there called me the
Mad Men on the hill because I had all
these sort of crazy ideas but the show I
think was very much about the government
we wish we had you know how we wish it
worked and that the ideals not perfect
but these men and women you know always
had a personal reason why they believed
or striving for for what they were
trying to achieve but it was in the best
sense as opposed to so much of what we
often feel and see which is the Craven
side of government I mean just look at
the
you know the number of people who are
indicted or heading toward jail or you
know it's it's uh you know the West Wing
was sort of the unfortunately not
necessarily real but in its own way
quite authentic version of what we wish
our government was and maybe what the
highest ideals of those who founded you
know who wrote the Declaration of
penance or the Constitution or you know
what they envisioned for America how did
you react to the criticism that the West
Wing was liberal well I mean it's one
what's wrong with taking a stand and
that doesn't mean you don't want to hear
other people disagree or argue with it
and the show had a sort of dance to it
that I thought was electric whatever the
the viewpoint so that it was at times
funny and it was a time smart hey bring
on those who are just as smart who have
a different point of view that's that's
great you know back to the book you the
impact on your family of this book being
written
what was it I think you know it's it's
twofold one is I think some really feel
it was a great thing to finally talk
about this it these things others are
still you know they are very much you
why did you you don't need to do that
you know we are from New England so we
maintain you know our version of silence
and and the other part is coming from a
large family is like when I showed to my
brother in manuscript he said you know I
Wow I think it's really good of course
it's not what happened because in a
large family you know I can remember
hearing in Massachusetts discussions
like how to get a certain place on Cape
Cod and the argument could go on for 45
minutes so the best way to get there you
know so you know anytime you have
several family members in a large family
you're gonna have a discussion about hey
I was there that's not what happened but
that's part of the book too is he's
learning that I was never gonna know
exactly what happened in every case and
I could only use sort of the limitations
of my memory and often that it was not
me discovering what happened but me
wishing I knew more you know that I wish
I knew more about my
I wish I knew more about my uncle and
that one of the things we don't usually
ask is enough questions before those who
come before us die what about the female
side of the equation is your mother
alive when you wrote this says it's
beautifully written and wish wish that
probably I didn't talk about things
certain things so much you know and
Doug's mother is still alive and she
would probably say it exactly the same
you know your you know why do you want
to stir things up again it would be part
of her response I think for me it was I
think also been honoring Doug you know
don't want I think much of what I do is
to say let's honor veterans I mean
veterans can be as whiny and is crazy in
a certain sense as anybody on the other
hand they have done something and served
and we have to honor them so honoring
Doug and also honoring I hope my father
my uncle and what about you did you
serve in the military no and I think
that's probably one of the reasons I
kept flunking physical for a stupid you
know football injuries and I think
that's one reason that I and not I alone
it's sort of but if Vietnam was sort of
the crucial event and issue of my
generation
John sacred yang is the author